[Musique]
bonjour Le Bistro du théâtre à Montini
le Bretonneux qui nous accueille une
nouvelle fois pour café politique 5e
émission l'invité aujourd'hui Alexandra
Rosetti bonjouronour et bienvenue
première femme invitée dans cette
émission maire de voisin le le
Bretonneux vous êtes l'une des seules
femmes même la seule femme sur
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
vous le vivez comment c'est difficile de
faire de la politique en tant que femme
ah non non non c'est pas difficile c'est
au contraire je trouve que c'est un beau
challenge parce que c'est vrai que
d'être entouré d'homme et d'apporter un
regard une couche un peu féminine je
trouve que c'est plutôt sympathique et
voilà donc j'ai pas de difficulté
particulière vous êtes professeur
d'anglais à l'origine comment vous avez
découvert la politique alors un peu par
hasard même si je crois pas vraiment au
hasard en fait mais quand je suis
arrivée à à voisin ça devait être en
1900 98 euh en fait j'ai quand j'ai
aménagé il y avait une créperie à côté
de chez moi qui s'est transformée en pub
et euh il y a eu énormément de bruit de
tapage nocturnes enfin c'était assez
compliqué et donc du coup j'ai bah j'ai
j'ai pris un peu les choses en main j'ai
fait une pétition dans le quartier non
pas pour fermer le peuple mais pour
demander à ce qu'il y ait des horaires
et à ce que je dirais la tranquillité du
du voisinage soit respectée et c'est à
ce moment-là que sont arrivé les
élections les les les élections
municipales arrivaient de de 2001 et la
Paris éit devenue obligatoire donc ils
avaient besoin de femme et sérieusement
parce voilà d'être une femme en
politique ça peut aider aussi et donc
ils ont repéré quelqu'un qui ma fois
avait su peut-être s'affirmer dans le
quartier et donc ils sont venus enfin
l'équipe de Monsieur B de l'époque est
venu me chercher pour être sur sa liste
voilà comment comment les choses ont
démaré en politique mais il fallait une
étiquette vous avz choisi celle du du
centre malgré tout par la suite alors à
cette époque là j'avais pas du tout
d'étiquette j'avais pas forcément de de
conscience politique affirmée encore à
ce moment-là monsieur Biet était à l'UDF
à l'époque et moi ça me convenait le
côté un petit peu
modéré me plaît beaucoup donc voilà j'ai
suivi sans sans état d'âme on va dire et
vous êtes bien au centre aujourd'hui
politique le centre c'est ce qui vous
convient parfaitement je pense que ce
qui me convient parfaitement parce que
justement il y a il y a un équilibre il
y a une recherche
d'équilibre une recherche d'harmonie je
trouve par rapport aux décisions qu'il y
a à prendre et moi je je m'y retrouve
parfaitement je vais revenir un peu sur
l'historique alors que je vais dresser
assez rapidement rentrer donc au conseil
municipal à voisin le Bretonneux mare
adjointe à la démocratie locale 2001-
200008 première adjointe jusqu'en 2013
de ces années vous ne gardez pas
forcément un bon souvenir puisque le 1er
octobre 2013 vous avez démissionné vous
quittez la majorité qui est donc menée à
l'époque par Alexi Biette avec des
désaccords sur les finances sur
l'urbanisme également pourquoi vous avez
décidé de persévérer en politique si
vous avez été échaudé un petit peu par
cette expérience et que vous êtes parti
un peu fâché alors d'abord parce que ça
a été 1è ans passionnant quand même je
veux dire il faut pas voir que le
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de négatif si je
suis repartie c'est quand même qu'il y
avait des choses qui me plaisaient et en
particulier j'ai été beaucoup au contact
des habitants parce que en démocratie
locale bah c'était les conseils de
quartier le Conseil Municipal des Jeunes
j'ai organisé avec le conseil municipal
de l'époque Monsieur beeu qui travaille
avec moi on a organisé beaucoup de
choses pour améliorer la démocratie
locale ensuite travailler dans une
équipe c'est pas toujours c'est pas
toujours facile c'est pas toujours
simple et c'est vrai qu'il y a des
choses qui me qui ne me plaisaient plus
je m'en suis expliqué au moment de la
campagne
ça vous a pas dégoûté de la politique
non euh non non non non parce que il
faut faire la part des choses hein
justement je me suis dit au début je
m'étais dit je ne repars pas du tout
j'arrête j'avais même pour tout vous
dire commencé à m'inscrire à une
formation pour être chef d'établissement
donc j'avais vraiment envie de toute
façon d'évoluer et puis c'est vrai que
je me suis dit après tout c'est bien
beau de toujours critiquer de pas être
d'accord et je me suis dit peut-être je
pouvais apporter une contribution ma
pierre et donc j'ai décidé de de me
lancer en me disant bah voilà après tout
je peux tenter aussi ma chance et
proposer autre chose on va s'arrêter sur
ce moment où vous quittez tout de même
la majorité parce que les propos sont
dures des deux côtés aussi bien d'Alexis
bi donc le maire en place que de que de
votre part vous écrivez quand on est
première adjointe à voisin on seit ou
bien on démissionne c'était sur un
détract qui a été distribué c un moment
difficile pas sur le plan politique mais
sur le plan humain déjà ah oui oui oui
ça ça a ét un moment très difficile sur
le plan humain parce que ce sentiment de
pas avoir été écouté de pas avoir
d'avoir été mise de côté de plus en plus
les élection se approchait et plus on me
mettait sur la touche alors que je pense
que j'ai apporté ma pierre que j'ai
beaucoup soutenu monsieur Biet en toutes
les épreuves qu'il a traversé he je dire
en 2001 j'étais à ses côté quand il y a
eu le le fameux PCH c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça que je me suis retrouvé
adjointe en 2008 j'étais à ses côté
quand il y a encore eu une une session
dans l'équipe et j'ai trouvé que le
retour était quand même très très léger
on va dire et humainement en fait le
deuxième mandat humainement était très
compliqué vous avez ensuite gagné ces
élections municipales d'une quinzaine de
voix il y a eu un recours qui a été
déposé par Alex Biet il a fait un nouvel
appel d'ailleurs puisque la décision
vous était favorable on maintenait le
résultat donc c'est encore en suspens
quels sont les rapports aujourd'hui vous
avez au sein de de ce conseil munpendu
parce que parce que Monsieur Biet se
permet des tractes
diffamatoires manipule tout ce que on a
pu faire a essayé de se la zisanie au
moment de la rentrée d'affoler les
parents avec des informations
mensongères et moi j'ai décidé que
jamais de la vie je ne me ferai
laisserai marcher sur les pieds de cette
façon je j'estime qu'il faut être
honnête il peut être dans mon opposition
enfin je veux dire s'opposer à ce que je
à ce que je mets en place avec mon
équipe c'est tout à fait son droit mais
je je ne supporte pas la manipulation et
le mensonge et j'aimerais quand même
rappeler une chose parce que cette
histoire de 15 voix effectivement tout
le monde me dit d'ailleurs les 15 voix
c'est nous bon très bien je l'ai rappelé
dans une lettre que j'ai écrit au bcois
il y a pas très longtemps c'est c'est
presque 800 voir Moné entre deux tours
je n'avais aucun soutien de partie et
nous étions dans un triangulaire donc
les 15 voix c'est vraiment quatre
candidatures au premier tour trois
effectivement sur le
deè moi c'est une belle victoire c'est
pas juste 15 voix ça veut dire que quand
même il y avait une envie de changement
c'est c'est absolument évident juste
pour conclure cette première partie
aujourd'hui fin novembre vous vous
sentez comment dans vos habits de mer
très bien très bien je trouve que c'est
passionnant je je ne regrette pas
d'avoir être parti dans cette aventure
et puis j'ai une belle équipe à mes
côtés qui travaille qui s'investit et
beaucoup de dossiers qui qui vous occupe
on va en parler dans un instant au cours
de la seconde partie de ce café
politique toujours avec Alexandra
Rosetti maire de voisin
[Musique]
bretonne seconde partie de ce café
politique avec Alexandra Rosetti MRE udi
de Voisins le bretonneux nous avons
parlé tout à l'heure brièvement de votre
parcours on va parler à présent de de la
ville une ville d'un peu plus de 11000
habitants et puis ce sont les habitants
justement qui vont commencer par donner
leur avis je vous laisse les exp au
niveau des qualités de la ville c'est
vivant il y a des animations il y a les
commerces donc ça c'est niquel qui a un
certain
charme une facilité à vivre qui est tout
à fait agréable ce que j'aimerais de
mieux mais je ne sais pas que ça reste
que ça reste comme ça que ça ne se
détériore pas que les qualités de vie
restent les même une salle de fête
permettant faire du théâtre plus souvent
à voisin la salle de la tour est trop
peti et deuxièmement des logements pour
des personnes retraitées qui ne peuvent
plus assumer leur maison on est toujours
en attente d'amélioration au niveau de
la circulation bon moi ça y est
j'aiarrêté de bosser donc ça va mais
c'est vrai que surtout en ce moment avec
les travaux c'est c'est pas la gloire
peut-être pour les plus jeune ça bouge
peut-être pas beaucoup mais vous avez le
centre qui est quand même pas loin mais
c'est vrai que ça monte peut-être de de
structure pour pour les plus jeunes
peut-être voilà pour ce bref micro
trottoir de de la population on va
parler de la circulation forcément
pendant long moment tout à l'heure vous
n'y échapperez pas mais peut-être sur
les autres aspects sur l'animation salle
de fête une place pour les plus jeunes
quel regard vous portez sur ça sur ce
qui a été dit bah je je suis assez je
comprends tout à fait l'attente
l'attente des habitants
maintenant il faut qu'on enfin il faut
être aussi très prudent sur ce qu'on
peut promettre ou pas parce que la
situation économique n'est pas brillante
pour les collectivité local quelle
qu'elle soit je pense que le
gouvernement a a annoncé beaucoup
d'économie donc je je moi j'ai toujours
dit je ne partirai pas dans la
surenchère de promesse d'équipement
nouveaux qu'on ne pourrait pas ensuite
assumer c'est-à-dire que ce qu'on n pas
vu là aussi c'est que les Binois parlent
beaucoup aussi de leurs impôts et donc
créer de nouvelles structures c'est
aussi à ce moment-là il faut les
financer et comme l'état ne nous donne
de moins en moins de
dotation il y a un moment si on veut
vraiment financer beaucoup de choses
nouvelles il faudra recourir à l'impôt
donc c'est pas vraiment là-dessus je me
suis engagé en en campagne il y a des
choses des engagements qui ont été pris
pendant la campagne que vous ne pourrez
pas tenir des réalisations que vous
soutiez faire et devant la situation
économique devant les finances les
dotations de l'État vous êtes obligé de
mettre en suspens de reculer non parce
que j'ai été extrêmement prudente
pendant la campagne justement parce que
j'ai pas voulu faire de promesses que je
ne pourrais pas tenir et j'ai toujours
dit que il y aurait des sujets sur
lesquel on serait amené à se pencher
c'est-à-dire on étudie la question si on
ne peut pas le faire on explique
pourquoi on ne peut pas le faire voilà
donc j'ai été très prudente sur
d'éventuel je dirais nouveau nouveaux
projets au cours du fait politique vous
le savez nous sollicitons le le groupe
arrivé 2e mais en tête dans l'opposition
je le précise parce qu'il y a eu
quelques interrogations chez certains
conseillers municipaux dans dans
différentes villes c'est un choix que
nous assumons que j'assume également
donc sur voisin le Bretonneux nous
sommes allés voir Alexis Getz qui est
donc arrivé second sur ce scrutin et il
vous interpelle tout d'abord sur la
question des
finances concernant le personnel et et
les finances
euh combien de postes
va-t-il falloir supprimer en mairie pour
compenser les baisses de
dotation dans les orientations
budgétaires
2014 auquel madame marosetti avait
participé nous avions prévu de limiter
l'augmentation de la masse salariale à
15% une fois élu elle a augmenté d'un
tiers cette augmentation passant à 2 %
et dans la communation
municipale on nous annonce 250000 €
d'économie alors qu'en penser quel
stratégie pour l'ensemble du
mandat quelle stratégie pour le mandat
question sont les les finances en fait
c'est pour être bien clair c'est quoi
c'est la la masse salarielle qui est en
hausse alors que vous annoncez des
économies non alors Monsieur monsieur
Biet joue sur les mots mais je vais vous
expliquer la masse salariale elle
représente à peu près 60 % du budget de
fonctionnement donc il est évident qu'on
peut pas rester à c'est le premier poste
de dépense de la ville si on doit faire
des économies il est évident que la
masse salariale c'est ce qu'on doit
toucher je veux dire pour faire des
économies ce que Monsieur Biet explique
là en fait il confond il confond budget
et réalisé ce qui m'avait reproché
pendant la campagne en fait il leur fait
lui-même c'est assez
amusant effectivement ils avaient décidé
d'une augmentation de la masse salariale
de plus 1 et demi ce qui est assez
faible hein puisque en général ça on va
dire que les les chiffres que nous avons
aujourd'hui montrent qu'on est plutôt on
a plutôt été à plus 4 % par an ces
dernières années donc 1 et demi c'est
ambitieux il avait annoncé qu'il
supprimerait quatre postes quand je suis
arrivé en mars aucun poste n'avait été
supprimé et il n'y avait aucun plan pour
supprimer le moindre poste donc j'avoue
ou alors son administration ne m'a pas
ne m'a pas alerté on va dire donc
j'avoue que en arrivant c'était très
difficile de tenir cette ce plus 1 et
demi dans la mesure où rien n'avait
encore été fait depuis le mois de
janvier moi ce que j'ai fait c'est que
j'ai suivi la vie des services qui m'ont
alerté en me disant attention plus 1 et
demi c'est peut-être pas raisonnable par
rapport au fait qu'on a encore rien fait
ils m'ont demandé d'inscrire euh à la la
décision modificative plus 2 %. mais ce
qui va nous dire l'augmentation réelle
c'est le compte administratif qui va
être présenté en mars 2015 vous voyez
donc le budget prévoit les choses le
compte administratif c'est ce qui a été
effectivement fait et c'est vrai que
depuis que je suis arrivé on a supprimé
cinq postes pratiquement presque six
postes d'accord sans la moindre douleur
c'est-à-dire qu'on a fait en fonction
des départs des départs à ite ou des
départs dans d'autres collectivit il y a
pas de suppression sèche nous avons
réorganisé les services de la ville et
personne je pense en ville ne serait
capable vraiment de dire quel poste nous
avons supprimé donc voyez donc sur les
finances il y aura des économies de
faite elles ont déjà commencé elles ont
commencé c'est une question de méthode
en fait moi je veux pas faire d'effets
d'annonce je trouve que par rapport au
personnel en plus annoncé comme ça en
début d'année on va supprimer quatre
postes c'est extrêmement anxiogène parce
qu'on tout le monde se regarde en se
disant bah qui dans les CDD va va
disparaître et cetera on fait pas les
choses comme ça il faut avoir un plan il
faut envisager l'avenir et avoir un plan
sur le le personnel à long terme pour
vérifier au moment des départs à la
retraite qui on remplace qui on ne
remplace pas là sur les départs à la
retraite qui arrivent j'en ai déjà
quelques-uns donc je sais que je n'ai
pas besoin de les remplacer voilà ce que
Monsieur B oublié de dire c'est quand
même que pendant des années pour finir
la masse salariale a été quelque chose
de plutôt confortable à voisin et n'a
pas du tout été maîtrisé donc me
demander aujourd'hui de faire en
quelques mois que lui n'a pas fait en 19
ans c'est un petit peu voilà on sent les
rapports toujours très tendus hein avec
avec l'ancien ma mais parce que voilà je
veux dire on parle de budget donc on
parle de choses qu'on prévoit moi j'ai
voulu être plus prudente en m'appuyant
sur la vie des services maintenant c'est
le compte administratif qui dira combien
de combien elle a réellement augmenté en
2014 et je peux déjà vous dire on vote
le budget là en décembre ce qui est une
première aussi puis qu'avant on le
votait en mars donc on a fait un gros
travail pour pouvoir le voter en
décembre et là on prévoit une une
augmentation de plus 1 seulement je je
reviens quand même sur ce rapport un peu
tendu parce qu'il y a on va faire une
petite parenthèse vous êtes élu à la
communauté d'agglomération de Saint
Quentin 2uxème vice-présidente et vous
siégez dans la majorité donc avec Alexis
biett pour le coup oui c'est particulier
non c'est pasoprénique un petit peu
d'être dans l'opposition dans un rapport
très conflictuel au-delà même de la
simple opposition politique parce que
finalement vous êtes centre centre droit
même famille politique vous siégez
ensemble à l'agglomération et vous
arrivez à vous entendre au sein de
l'agglomération bah oui on est bien
obligé toute façon ce qui est dommage
c'est que vu vu le contexte actuel c'est
très difficile on peut pas travailler
ensemble on pourrait travailler sur
voisin sur ce que voisin veut porter
d'une seule voix bon pour l'instant
c'est pas encore possible mais quand
quand cet appel se recours et cetera
tout çaa sera derrière nous je pense
j'espère qu'on pourra travailler
intelligemment et au sein de
l'agglomération vous vous sentez bien
avec cette étiquette udi au sein de la
majorité je vous pose cette question
parce que pendant la campagne on va
revenir un petit peu sur les choses pour
les gens qui n'habitent pas voisins mais
alexette avait eu l'investiture UMP
soutenu par l'UDI dans le cadre des
différents accord alors que vous êtes à
l'UDI finalement au deuxème tour les
choses avaient été un petit peu
compliquées puis aujourd'hui vous êtes
pleinement à l'UDI vous serez même
candidate pour les élections
départementales sous cette couleur
politique là avec avec Yve vanval sur
sur votre canton qui lui est de l'UMP au
sein de l'UMP on vous dit pas quelque
fois bon ok il y a des difficultés avec
Alexis Biet mais faut calmer le jeu on
vous dit pas de calmer le jeu non non
non ne me dit rien puis j'estime que de
toute façon ça regarde pas les partis
c'est là effectivement il y a peut-être
quelque chose de plus personnel qui joue
aussi moi je j'attends que les choses
s'apaisent parce que je n'aime pas
travailler dans le conflit je c'est pas
c'est pas mon c'est pas ma façon de voir
la vie et donc j'attends que les choses
s'apaisent et je serai prête à
travailler avec lui voilà mais je comme
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure je pense
qu'après il faut faire attention à ce
qu'on écrit quand on écrit au vcinois et
moi je tiens beaucoup à à l'honnêteté de
ce qu'on de ce qu'on dit voilà et cette
candidature au départemental puisque
c'est tout récent pourquoi cet
engagement sur votre canton parce que il
me semble très important que voisin soit
représenté au niveau du département il y
a des enjeux à voisins en matière de
circulation en particulier qui font
qu'on ne peut pas rester sur le bord de
la route indéfiniment voisin n'a jamais
été représenté au conseil départemental
et je pense que pour les habitants c'est
c'est vraiment important qu'il y ait
quelqu'un de voisin qui soit là vous
serez candidate avec V valal puisque
maintenant c'est un binôme qui se
présente pour ces élections ancienne
élection cantonale aujourd'hui
départementale la circulation justement
c'est revenue beaucoup dans le dans le
micro trottoir lorsqu'on discute avec
les habitants sur le le cas de la RD 36
par exemple il y a eu une
expérimentation qui a été menée sur la
circulation nouvelle programmation des
feux quel quel bilan on peut en faire
puisqu'on arrive à la fin de
l'expérimentation voilà on va arriver à
la fin là je je suis en train de
reprendre rendez-vous avec le Conseil
Général justement avec Monsieur vanval
pour faire un point sur cette
expérimentation dont le but était de
fluidifier la circulation en passant de
quatre phases à trois phases pour les
feux et donc on est on a imaginer enfin
le Conseil général nous a proposé donc
ce ce principe d'un petit rond-point
pour voir un petit peu ce que ça ça
donne moi de mon côté j'ai mis en ligne
un questionnaire sur le site de la ville
euh assez précis en demandant aux gens à
quelle heure il passaient d'où il
venaient et cetera pour parce que je me
suis je me suis engagé à ça aussi
c'est-à-dire j'ai dit on expérimente des
choses mais il faut qu'il y ait un
retour de l'usager il faut que l'usager
puisse donner son avis parce que c'est
quand même lui qui passe là tous les
jours et donc on a eu beaucoup de
beaucoup de retours sur ce questionnaire
je crois qu'on a pas loin de 200 200
retours ce qui est ce qui est vraiment
positif et probablement représentatif
mais le problème c'est que c'est très
les réponses sont très variées en fait
on a d'un côté des gens qui trouvent que
c'est beaucoup mieux travers ses voisins
est plus facile à priori par contre
selon la direction dont vient bah ça
peut être plus difficile et puis aussi
peut-être un côté un sentiment
d'insécurité par rapport à à parce que
les gens savent pas toujours comment
prendre ce ce rond-point donc il faut
qu'on fasse un point rapidement avec le
CG pour pour voir un petit peu quelle
suite on donne rien effigé pour
l'instant non c'est une expérimentation
et et de toute façon il faut améliorer
la la circulation dans C eur ainsi qu'en
amont on reste sur la circulation
justement seconde question d'Alexis
Biet l'aménagement la fin de
l'aménagement de la rue de la mer anaise
obtenue par la précédente équipe a été
réalisé cet été et donc ma question est
pourquoi avoir
abandonné les petites chicanes qui
permettent de dissuader le trafic de
transit au profit de trois feux
tricolores
coûteux et dont l'utilité n'est pas
encore avérée et que devient-il de cette
de ce contournement de voisins promis de
nombreuses fois pendant la campagne pour
faire transiter le trafic en dehors de
voisins je vous laisse répondre ah ben
oui c'est un beau sujet la rue de la
merenaise alors Monsieur Biet à la
mémoire courte puisqu'il a lui-même
demandé un feu à Monsieur Houillon
puisquen fait il nous fallait
l'autorisation le ma de Man
voilà donc j'ai un courrier où Monsieur
Houillon refuse ce feu et lui propose à
la place un céd le passage voyez donc il
avait lui-même fait la demande donc bon
très bien effectivement dès que je suis
arrivée je suis allée voir Monsieur
Houillon avec j'en avais discuté avec le
président de la SL
Champ-Fleuri ce quartier a une
difficulté c'est-à-dire que les Vinois
et ça c'était une promesse de campagne
j'ai dit je veux faire respirer voisin
pour les Vinois donc les Vinois dir
avait difficultés à sortir de le
résidence de la la rue Victor Hugo ou de
la rue de laaméranta parce que il y a un
flux continu de voiture vers 8h 8h30 du
matin qui arrive de Manil lesamoau et en
plus on a une école juste à côté donc on
passe devant l'école euh et donc ça crée
forcément non seulement des bouchons de
l'insécurité et puis ça empêche les gens
de voisins de circuler donc je suis allé
voir Monsieur
Ouillon qui m'a dit oui euh enfin je
crois qu'il a il a entendu mes arguments
euh l'idée étant que le feu ne
fonctionne que le matin c'est-à-dire que
il est là pour réguler la circulation à
l'heure de pointe le matin le reste de
la journée le feu est auouvert parce
qu'on ne veut pas non plus empêcher les
manicis de circuler ni de venir dans les
commerces de voisins évidemment alors
les chicanes euh c'est pas forcément
dirait la panassée ou la solution idéale
ce qui n'avait pas été très très bien
fait en amont c'est la concertation avec
les gens qui habitent dans cette rue et
moi j'ai pris beaucoup de temps avec eux
je suis allé sur place plusieurs fois
nous les voyons régulièrement parce que
c'est eux qui vivent ça au quotidien et
qui sont capables de nous dire là on a
effectivement des problèmes de vitesse
donc là on est en train de regarder pour
aménager peut-être quelques
stationnements qui pourront réduire a
cette vitesse donc il y a une vraie
problématique parce que nous sommes avec
nos voisins il est pas question non plus
de mettre monsieur Houillon en
difficulté avec ses habitants mais euh
ma responsabilité c'est aussi de
protéger l'école et puis de faire en
sorte que les Vinois puissent sortir de
chez eux en toute sécurité et la
circulation c'est un dossier qui
pourrait devenir encore plus
problématique parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de logements de construction qui sont
prévus sur la ville de voisin le
bretonneé on va pas rentrer dans dans
tout le détail mais quartier du Merant
manivelle les mouette aussi la remise le
cœur de ville qui doit être réaménagé
aussi de nouveau logement pourquoi déjà
cette course à l'urbanisme à la
construction parce que c'est obligé pour
maintenir le nombre d'habitants déjà
alors c'est pas une course à l'urbanisme
enfin en tout beaucoup de projet ça fait
beaucoup de projets qui ont été démarrés
d'ailleurs avant euh moi je trouve que
par exemple le projet qui qui vient de
sortir de terre enfin qui va être livré
là mois de décembre par Kaufman et et
est trop trop important par rapport
justement nos capacités d'accueil de
dessertes faut absorber ça veut dire la
circulation des écoles des commerces
enfin tout ce qui va AC le feu de la rue
de laamantesse peut aussi servir à ça
puisqu'on sait qu'on a énormément de
voitures qui vont de nouveau sortir de
ces immeubles là ensuite avec le le le
méranté quand il sera terminé donc il y
a un moment il faut quand même réguler
la circulation et essayer de décourager
un peu le passage là le matin voyez ce
feu il a quand même quelques util
quelques enfin une utilité
euh donc non il y a pas de course à
l'urbanisation il faut simplement se
projeter dans l'avenir c'est ce que nous
demande l'état euh et puis aussi ce que
nous demande beaucoup de gens
c'est-à-dire que les jeunes en
particulier hein mais pas que parce
qu'on a parlé des personnes âgées tout à
l'heure aussi il y a un vrai besoin in
de de se loger et à voisin comme il y a
30 ans les élus on ont prévu les choses
en disant voisins ce sera résidentiel
donc on aun habitat je dirais horizontal
très prononcé dans notre ville
maintenant on patie un peu de ça on a
des obligations imposées par l'État
c'est 25 % de logements sociaux ce qui
est quand même assez consid dans les
nouveaux logements il y aura une grande
part réservée pour ces logements sociaux
parce que la ville de voisin n'est pas
dans les quotas aujourd'hui he sur la
loi
s voilà alors ce que je voudrais juste
préciser c'est que souvent les gens me
disent bon bah oui d'accord on va payer
une amende et cetera mais ce que l'État
fait parce que il y a des villes qui
choisissent qui auraient pu choisir ou
fait préfère payer des amendes plutôt
que d'avoir des logements sociaux sauf
que maintenant l'état si on ne respecte
pas nos obligations on a des obligations
tous les 3 ans triénales si on ne les
respecte pas l'état reprend la main le
préfet peut urbaniser à notre place donc
moi j'ai pas tellement envie que ce soit
le préfet qui décide qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et où je pense que c'est bien que
nous Ress maître de notre aménagement
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on
montre qu'on a la volonté d'aménager
notre ville de construire maintenant je
ne fais pas une course au logement une
course au logements sociaux j'essaie de
définir et j'ai demandé à l'aglo de la
communauté d'agglomération de travaill
dans ce sens cet été on a vraiment
retravaillé sur les besoins des
vissinois fa savoir que l'équipe de
Monsieur Biet enfin je dis monsieur Biet
plutôt parce que moi j'étais dans
l'équipe j'étais pas au courant avait
quand même accepté 110 logements
d'inseron sociale sur la ville inserçon
sociale ce sont des personnes en très
grande difficulté qui ont des
difficultés d'insertion donc je dis pas
qu'il faut tourner le dos à ces gens-là
mais 11 logements il y en avait 60 au
plein centrreeville et 50 sur la remise
donc là vous les avez supprimé bah oui
parce que parce que nous n'avons pas
nous n'avons d'jord pas notre CCS n'est
pas dimtionné pour ça et puis ça ne
répond pas au besoins des Vinois pour le
coup voyez donc après si le le préfet
souhaite qu'on qu'on en mette une petite
partie on retavaillera la question mais
voyez je veux dire c'est en fait ce que
j'ai découvert moi c'est un nombre de
logements spécifiques un petit peu
partout sur la ville euh et je me suis
posé la question est-ce que ça
correspond vraiment à notre besoin notre
envie euh à l'envie des Vinois quand les
gens disent on n pas envie que notre
cadre vie change change trop B ça veut
dire qu'il faut maîtriser il faut rester
maître de notre aménagement il faut être
maître de notre aménagement aussi avec
les promoteurs voyez qui arrivent qui
achètent ou qui font des promesses de
vente avec des avec des particuliers et
puis qui nous propose des projets qui ne
sont peut-être pas ce qu'on voudrait
voir sur la ville voyz vous voulez
garder la main sur la ville garder le le
contrôle que ce soit l'urbanisme que ce
soit la circulation on l'a compris aussi
ça s'exprime à travers votre candidature
pour le pour le Conseil départemental en
mars prochain juste une toute dernière
question une agglomération de 800000
habitants comme c'était souhaité par le
préfet de région ça doit vous faire peur
un peument parce que pour conserver
cette aspect vage petite ville de voisin
BR de 800000 habitants ça vare ça va
devenir très compliqué l'élargissement
de l'agglomération idéale pour vous ce
serait quoi je pense que ce que propose
le je dirais la la branche droite de
l'aglo aujourd'hui me semble raisonnable
c'estàdire ajouter CIN communes qui sont
dans notre bassin de vie il y a plein de
sujets je veux dire la le sujet sujet de
la gouvernance la plupart des des aglos
des alentours ne fonctionne pas comme
nous la communauté de saint-quanttin en
iveline a quand même une un
fonctionnement assez optimum très très
organisé d'un point de vue administratif
et à des compétences que les autres
communautés d'agglomération n'ont pas
donc déjà je veux dire arriver à faire
travailler t tous ces ces différents
types de de PCI ensemble ça c'est quand
même pas simple donc ça me semble un
peue sur 800000 habitants bah non parce
que parce qu'on va perdre on va perdre
en proximité moi ce que j'ai oup entendu
pendant la campagne électorale c'est
vraiment ce besoin de proximité ce
besoin de comprendre ce que les élus
font pourquoi ils le font et et de
participer donc à 800000 habitants ça
veut dire qu'on est noyé dans quelque
chose qui nous échappe et je crois pas
que ce soit la volonté des des habitants
aujourd'hui merci Alexandra roséti maire
de Voisins le bretonneux café politique
revient le 13 décembre je recevrai
Bertrand Ouillon votre voisin le maire
de
[Musique]
maniamour